well you know Nancy Pelosi good old
Nancy Pelosi she's a Catholic and she
takes her faith very very seriously uh
or or she would like us to believe that
she does and yesterday she was asked at
a press conference whether she wants to
impeach President Trump because she
hates him if that's really her
motivation and she was she was very
offended by the question here was her
answer when it comes to helping our kids
who are afraid of gun violence I think
he is cool when he doesn't deal with
helping our dreamers though of which
were very proud I think he's in denial
about the Constitution about the climate
crisis however that's about the election
this is about the elect take it up in
the election this is about the
Constitution of the United States and
the facts that leads to the president's
violation of his oath of office and as a
Catholic I resent your using the word
hate in a sentence that addresses me I
don't hate anyone I was raised in a way
that is full a heart full of love and
always prayed for the president and I
still pray for the president I pray for
the president all the time so don't mess
with me when it comes to words like that
first of all I her hand motions are very
distracting because they appear to be
disconnected from what she's actually
saying and it sort of freaks me out it's
it's just just the president is a coward
who doesn't care about dreamers and he's
trying to kill the planet and he puts
ketchup on his steak it just it doesn't
make sense there should be some connect
between but more to the point um she
says that she's a as a cat and she
doesn't hate anyone and in fact she has
a heart full of love Nancy Pelosi has a
heart full of love no hate for anyone
maybe that's true actually
because the millions of children whose
execution she supports and helps fund
and facilitate the unborn children well
she doesn't hate them it's true
Haytham she just has a total disregard
for them so that's what she means she
means I don't hate anybody I just have a
wanton disregard for their well-being
okay then
well that thanks for clearing that up
now of course Pelosi invoking her
alleged Catholicism is is farcical she's
not a Catholic and I can say that how do
I know that
well because being a Catholic means a
certain thing just like being a Jew or
being a Muslim one of the things that it
means if you're say you're a Catholic is
that you believe in the authority of the
Catholic Church there's no such thing as
a well I'm a Catholic but the Catholic
Church doesn't know what it's talking
about type of Catholic now there are a
lot of people who claim to be that kind
of Catholic but that can't really exist
that's like saying you're a Cowboys fan
but you hate the Cowboys and you love
the Redskins well then you're not a
Cowboys by definition then you're not a
Cowboys then you can't be a Catholic
while denying the authority of the
church on moral matters which isn't to
say that a Catholic has to agree with
every opinion or every word that comes
out of the Pope's mouth thank God no
that's not what it means what I'm
talking about are the doctrines of the
church which the Pope cannot just change
on a whim and no Pope ever has even the
current one so Nancy Pelosi thinks that
the church is wrong about abortion not
to mention issues like marriage and
sexuality sexual morality in order for
the church to be wrong about those
issues it would have to be just a human
institution and nothing more entirely
fallible entirely capable of being wrong
about even basic moral truths and I'm
sure that is how every non Catholic sees
the church but if you are a Catholic
then you can't see the church that way
doesn't make any sense to see the church
that way by definition this is one of
the reasons why it also doesn't make
sense when we talk about bishops and
priests withholding communion from
pro-abortion politicians who come to
their churches which is something that
happens sometimes should happen a lot
more than it does but it doesn't make
sense when people say that they disagree
with
withholding communion and I hear this I
hear this from Catholics I hear from non
Catholics saying why I don't think they
should do that disagree the the doctrine
of the Catholic Church is that Christ is
really present in the Eucharist real
presence so it's not symbolic he's
really present there in a mystical
supernatural way and so as the teaching
goes if you're in a state of mortal sin
you can't receive it you have to go to
confession first get things right and
then and then you can go again if you're
not a Catholic and you disagree with the
metaphysical claims about the Eucharist
then you know I understand that I would
expect you to disagree if you agreed
with it I would expect you to be a
Catholic but to disagree specifically
with the rules surrounding who can
receive it that doesn't make any sense
if the church is right about the
Eucharist then it stands the reason that
it's right about the parameters around
which you can receive the Eucharist
the church is wrong about the Eucharist
or if you think the church is wrong
about there's no reason to be Catholic
and you shouldn't care what rules there
are and who can receive it who can't
religions
the point is religions are not your
personal little playthings that you can
do what you want with they're not like a
clump of play-doh in your hand that you
can mold into whatever shape you want it
to be there is no such thing as a Muslim
who rejects all the teachings of Islam
there is no such thing as a Mormon who
thinks the Book of Mormon is bogus there
cannot be in the same way any such thing
as a Catholic who thinks the church has
no idea what it's talking about on an
issue like abortion the central moral
issues of our time but that's that's
Pelosi's position it must be it has to
be given her radical consistent
unyielding support for abortion in the
abortion industry so Pelosi is a fraud
not to mention a facilitator of an
apologist for the mass murder of
children just so we're clear about that
before we move on you know when I talk
about stamps.com I always wonder who in
the world still goes to the post office
and why stamps calm brings the post
office right to you no need to interrupt
your work day to fight the traffic get
to the post office especially now during
the holidays you know going to the post
office is it's gonna be extra busy
because of all the people there setting
their packages and their holiday cards
that's why you need stamps calm anything
you could do with the post office you
could do it stamps calm stamps to calm
calm eliminates trips to the post office
and it saves you money with discounts
that you can't even get at the post
office so what you're doing with stamps
calm is you're saving time and money
which there's just no reason not to do
that what argument can you launch
against that you can't I defy you to
come up with an argument against it you
can't with stamps calm you get five
cents off every first class to have it
up to 40% off Priority Mail on top of
all the time you save as well don't
spend a minute of your holiday season at
the post office this year sign up for
stamps calm instead there's no risk with
my promo code Walsh you get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
Plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitment or contracts or
anything just go to stamps com click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page type in Walsh that stamps comm
enter Walsh stamps comm never go to the
post office again by the way this moment
from Biden well there's a lot you could
probably say about it but if you can't
laugh about it if you can't see the
humor in it then I don't know what to do
with you there's just something wrong
with you so here's what happened if you
haven't if you haven't seen the footage
here's what happened when a voter at a
town hall talking about and tried to
challenge Biden on on Ukraine and also
on on his age about whether or not he's
he's able to do the job and this is how
Biden reacted to the question the reason
I'm run is because I've been around and
I can get things done that's why I'm
running and you want to my son did not
any occasion and no one has ever said
you said I set up my son to work in the
morale company did not what you said get
your work straight jack
you don't even at MSNBC you did not hear
that at all what you heard look okay I'm
not gonna hit a hard man you man oh yeah
you do it but what look fat look here's
the deal
[Music]
listen Jack listen up bub your fat dummy
run laps around you do you even lift bro
that's gonna be Biden's new campaign
slogan vote for me you dumb fat bastards
and I have to say that's that's not a
bad sales pitch it really isn't I that's
the best sales pitch that the Biden
campaign has come up with yet I'll give
him that
now Biden's campaign is trying to claim
you you heard there you heard it he
called the guy fat he said look fat and
I think he was going for fat ass I
assume that's where he was headed with
that and then he stopped himself but
Biden's campaign they're trying to say -
no he didn't say he didn't say fat he
said fax wasn't fat fax so he was saying
look fax which of course makes no sense
but let's go back and listen again to
that particular part and we'll see did
he say fat or did they say facts listen
again okay one more time yeah he
definitely said fat that's definitely
called about a hundred percent remember
also he earlier he accused him of being
sedentary so there was a theme emerging
here he accused him of being sedentary
challenge him to a push-up contest and
then appeared to say fat and he did say
fat and I'll tell you one thing Joe
Biden would never talk to corn pop that
way I guarantee you that my favorite
thing though is just is this is my
favorite thing now in politics is Joe
Biden insulting people like it's the
1940s
listen Jack quit being a wiseguy cut the
malarkey why I've got half a mind to
give you a knuckle sandwich
I my only hope this is my this is my
dream my hope that eventually at a town
hall before this thing is over we will
get Joe Biden calling a female voter or
potential voter a dame that's my that's
my dream I just want to hear him
referring to a female as a dame I think
I think we'll get it okay hey I'm moving
on you know there's a recent article
from CBS News based on a soon-to-be
released CBS documentary and the article
slash documentary asks the question if
asked the question is there a better way
to raise boys to avoid toxic masculinity
that's the question and the article
details the trials and tribulations of
parents who are wanting to protect their
sons from the horrors of traditional
masculinity so one example given in the
article I'll read this to you it says
Roberto and 10/10 use a Santiago our
parents to their three children one of
whom is a boy who expresses himself by
occasionally wearing a dress or painting
his nails
Roberto remembers a moment when his son
wore a ponytail to school I said hey bud
I want you to know I love your hair I
think it's so cool but kids at school
might not understand and they might say
something about it and he got this look
he was just crestfallen just done he
took it out and he wouldn't wear it
Roberto says for me it was one of those
things as a parent where I'm like I'm
cool with this but the world is not
gonna be okay with this so what do I do
how do I protect him that crushed his
spirit that day even though I thought I
was trying to help him and we've got the
the founder of a group called a call to
man to men explaining that that boys
should not be taught to quote embody
certain ideals says this is a founder
saying we have coined a term called the
man box and that's a short form for the
collective socialization of men that
we've all been taught on some level not
asking for help always feeling like we
have to be in
trol dominating and having power over
others not expressing any emotion except
for anger all of those things are rigid
notions of manhood feeling like we have
to be in control that we have to control
things those are all things that are
rigid and that they don't bend and
meanwhile the article quotes a 20-17
study revealing some findings that the
author of the article says are
disturbing it says out of out of a one
thousand three hundred twenty eight men
between the ages of eighteen and thirty
surveyed in the u.s. seventy two percent
said they've been told that quote a real
man behaves a certain way the survey
also found 59 percent agree with the
statement that guys should act strong
even if they feel scared or nervous
inside and forty percent agree that men
should figure out their personal
problems on their own without asking
others for help more disturbingly twenty
three percent of respondents agreed that
men should use violence to get respect
if necessary and then it goes on with
more that there's a psychologist named
dr. Michael Reichert says that confirms
that these attitudes are very bad and
very harmful he says it's not the
experience of emotions that's different
between males and females it's the
expression of emotions expressions of
emotions follow follow what we call
feeling rules those feeling rules are
culture we tell girls don't be angry be
a lady we tell boys don't be scared
don't be vulnerable don't cry don't be
weak be strong be stoic keep it inside
that is profoundly damaging of how we
actually keep our minds present so the
main thrust of this is that boys in our
culture are broken and it is our
outdated and quote disturbing notions of
traditional masculinity that broke them
now I would say this is all wrong and
I'll explain why it's wrong in just a
moment but first have you ever wondered
why so many Americans are sick unhealthy
overweight between the the food supply
sedentary lifestyle speaking of people
being sedentary as Joe Biden was
Americans are in
in worse shape than ever and that's why
the team of on staff positions at
brickHouse nutrition nutrition created
field of greens field of greens it's an
easy way for you to add fruits and
vegetables to your daily routine without
spending hours in the produce section
hiring a home chef taking cheap
supplements it's to keep to keep produce
in your house it's expensive that it
goes bad you know this is just a lot
easier you get all the same nutrition
field greens is made with real USDA
organic fruits and vegetables
it also helps boost your immunity using
antioxidants and assist digestive health
as well so it's like having a doctor
nutritionist right there in your kitchen
for you to consult with and use one
scoop delivers a full serving of fruits
and vegetables just drop it in a cup of
water stirred and you're done
I use it for smoothies I think it's
great that way as well bottom line this
is real food not extracts you'll look
better you'll feel better go to brick
house Walsh calm and get 15% off your
first order just for trying it with
promo code Walsh that's brick house
Walsh com promo code Walsh so back to
this article the people interviewed for
the article along with the author
herself are perpetuating the very
problem that they say that they want to
solve because the real toxic thing here
is not masculinity it is the attitude
and an approach that you see
demonstrated and embodied in this
article and the people interviewed
traditional masculinity is not the
problem here the problem here is the
effort to tear down and dismantle
traditional masculinity so a few points
about this number one
if you're trying to help bullies out and
you're worried about the state of boys
in our culture and I agree there is
reason to be worried about that if you
look at the statistics men and boys
struggle in many areas in ways that
girls don't
if you look at you know everything from
drug abuse to homelessness prison
dropouts suicides all of them men are
vastly over-represented in all those
statistics so if you want to do
something about that you're on the wrong
foot already if you're beginning by
talking about toxic masculinity because
if you're talking about toxic
masculinity it seems like it could be
referring to one of two things number
one you could be referring to
traditionally masculine traits that
we've now decided are toxic or you could
be referring to actually harmful traits
that you associate with men and say
therefore are representations of toxic
masculinity now if you're using it in
the first sense if you're saying that
traditionally masculine naturally
masculine traits are toxic then that's
obviously degrading and damaging to men
especially boys because you're telling
them that their natural masculine
dispositions are somehow disordered
we'll get back to that in a minute but
in the second sense this is a problem
too because it unfairly blames
masculinity for bullying and
narcissistic behavior that has nothing
specifically to do with masculinity and
if you don't understand why men might
take an issue with that and might not
might not like that approach just
imagine how almost any woman would feel
if I said that gossipy materialistic
bimbos
suffer from toxic femininity that would
be at the very least an unnecessarily
inflammatory way of addressing a problem
and there's no reason to bring
femininity into it if I've got an issue
with materialistic bimbos there's no
reason to start talking about femininity
it's got nothing to do with it but worse
than that it would suggest that
femininity taken to a toxic extreme
results in materialistic bimbos so
it would seem to say that well it's okay
to be a woman but don't be too womanly
because then you're gonna end up like
that
now of course nobody ever does talk
about toxic femininity that's just not a
phrase anybody uses and in fact I
googled it just to see I googled toxic
femininity just to see if there is
anybody using the phrase and for the for
the most part it's it's just it's not
it's what you would expect it's just it
doesn't come up as much but one of the
first Google results if you go to any
google toxic femininity one of the first
results is an article and I think
Psychology Today or something explaining
what toxic femininity is and according
to this article toxic femininity is just
internalized misogyny so actually toxic
femininity is the fault of men also
toxic femininity in other words is
another version of toxic masculinity so
if the if the term has ever used it's
gonna be used in that way in a way that
somehow it blames men it's never gonna
be used in the same way that toxic
masculinity is used in reference to two
men so that's that's a problem
nobody ever you and so all you have to
do is think well
how would it seem how would I feel if
somebody did start using the phrase
toxic femininity in the same way that
they say toxic masculinity everybody
would just would would feel that it's
insulting and demeaning towards women
and it would be but if it's insulting
and demeaning towards women then it's
not hard to see how toxic masculinity is
insulting and demeaning towards men
second point is that they get into and
this is something we hear a lot about
well you don't we don't want to tell
boys that men act a certain way or this
is what a real man does no actually we
do want to tell boys that that's a very
positive and good message there's
nothing wrong with telling them to be
strong or encouraging them to exercise
control over their emotions obviously
these messages can be delivered in the
wrong way but the fundamental point is
is good and important
the problem in our culture isn't that
boys are being thrown into a man box or
forced to conform to some strict notion
of masculinity the problem is exactly
the opposite for for so many boys
they're given no instruction on how to
be a man no example to follow no
guidance on how to grow and mature in
their masculinity so the folks over at a
call to men talking about the man box
and how we have these rigid notions of
masculinity these these people are and
just like many people when they talk
about masculinity it's like they're
living in the 1940s just like Joe Biden
they haven't noticed that the era of the
strong and stoic man ended a long time
ago that's it's not like that anymore
we're now living in the era of drag
queens and feminism and gender fluidity
and fatherless homes most boys these
days have no clue how to be a man no
idea what to do with their masculine
energy because nobody has ever told them
nobody has ever showed them the fact of
the matter is this most boys
are born with a propensity to quote
behave a certain way
it's not an invention we didn't come up
with that there's a reason why nearly
every civilization in human history
across the world across time has come to
remarkably similar conclusions about the
sorts of things that men are supposed to
do
they didn't arbitrarily and
coincidentally invent the same social
construct for men no what they did is
they they noticed certain things about
men they noticed that men are naturally
aggressive and so they said well men
should be warriors they noticed that men
are stronger than women is they said say
this so they said well men should be the
protectors they noticed that men have a
greater desire and instinct to leave
their homes and go out into the wild and
so they said men should be hunters and
providers they noticed that boys have
lots of physical energy so they came up
with sports for boys to play the the
point is that societies until very
recently did not invent masculinity they
harnessed it they said this is what
masculinity is this is what men do this
is how they act this is how they're
inclined to act and so let's find useful
healthy ways for them to challenge or to
channel rather that masculine energy and
the same thing was done with women and
femininity but now nowadays we insist
despite all evidence to the contrary
that boys are not naturally inclined to
act any particular way or worse we say
that their natural inclinations are
toxic so this results in the best-case
scenario it results with boys who are
not given any roadmap to follow not
given any direction not told it all had
to be a man and in the worst case
scenario it results in in many cases
with parents teachers politicians etc
who set out to directly and
intentionally break a boy's spirit and
and cure him of his masculinity as if
it's cancer this is done with
psychiatric drugs it's done with hormone
pills it's done with with brainwashing
sessions with drag queens at the library
any number of equally insidious ways
just think about the school system as a
microcosm as an example of this if boys
are disproportionately struggling in
school and they are boys get worse
grades boys get punished more off and
they drop out more often but we look at
that boys are having a tough time in
school okay is it is it because the
school system is trying to put boys in a
rigid box of masculinity is that what's
happening you think that's what's
happening in the average public school
that they that their notions of
masculinity or too narrow and
traditional now of course not if boys
are put in any box at school
it's a box for girls that's the problem
the school system requires students to
sit for long periods of time remain calm
memorize information etc these are all
things that girls are very good at
naturally the problem for boys is that
they're not so good at those things
naturally and but they're forced to do
it anyway so it's not that they're
forced to be masculine it's that they're
not allowed to be masculine because I
think also about about the way that of
the rules and the way things are
punished so boys with again that
aggression that physical energy that
strength they're more likely if they
have a disagreement they don't like
somebody if they have a fight they're
more likely to punch each other in the
face that's what boys are more likely to
do whereas girls are more inclined to
cut each other down verbally spread
rumors that kind of thing now I think we
all know this about any of us who went
to school as kids
the verbal attacks the rumor
that are spread about you if you're an
adult now in your 20s 30s 40s 50s and
you still sometimes think about a form
of bullying that that happened to you
when you were a kid if you still feel
somewhat affected by it it's probably
not the time that you got punched in the
mouth
you probably don't think about that at
all it's it's gonna be the verbal that
you know the way you were cut down
verbally the rumors that stuff has a
lasting impact that stuff is is in so
many ways way worse than physical fights
you've got kids in school now who are
developing lifelong complexes that
things are happening that they're gonna
be in therapy for the next 30 years
because of it and it's not because they
got punched in the mouth
it's because of the of the the verbal
stuff the psychological stuff the
emotional stuff yet you know if boys get
mad at each other and they punch each
other in the face they could get
expelled it could have effects on their
whole it could ruin their life do you
expelled when you're 12 years old
that that could set you on a course
maybe not ruin but not your like your
life is over but it's gonna set you want
it's gonna profoundly change the course
of your life to be expelled let's say at
the age of 12
so yeah boys boys exhorting their their
anger in that way they're gonna they can
be expelled meanwhile girls expressing
their anger in ways that are far more
damaging what do they get stern
talking-to
maybe detention if that's probably
nothing in most cases so I would say
that if there's any rigid gender
construct being forced on boys and men
it is a feminine one after all we are
the first human civilization in human
history that has attempted to literally
turn boys into girls so when I say we're
trying to turn boys and the girls we are
literally trying to do that
just trying we think we've done it there
are a lot of people in this culture we
think that they that you not only can
you try but you can really do that so if
we really want to help boys
them for who they are
this is one thing this is our culture
supposed to be all about this
self-acceptance right how many marketing
campaigns how many self-help books have
been written about this well we should
need to accept boys for who they are as
boys and help them grow in that identity
not grow past it or beyond it or grow in
that identity you're a bully you're
masculine that's good
that's wonderful that's good for you
it's good for society it'll be good for
your family one day but here is how you
channel that this is a direction you go
with it that's the message we need to
have for boys in my opinion okay finally
have to mention this before we get the
emails South Korea has a new menu item
at their Papa John's locations it's
called the American pizza and here it is
take a look at this yes that's a a pizza
with hot dogs on every slice I have to
say as an American I find this to be an
offensive degradation of my culture also
secondarily I'll take two slices please
thank you I think actually the bigger
issue when you look at it is the cheese
on this pizza look it looks like cheese
whiz or sometng not mozzarella that's
not a complaint okay but I'm just trying
to figure it out and honestly some
people are offended by this Pizza if you
could put pineapple if you can put fruit
on a pizza then there's nothing wrong
with with hot dogs so lay off the South
Koreans on this one all right um you
know leftists have taken over the
culture in Hollywood in academia even
online it's dangerous because they want
to shut down open debate well in
theaters this Friday actually that's
would be today right yeah into in
theaters today starting Adam Carolla and
Dennis Prager no safe spaces is finally
being released Adam and Dennis take you
on a wild ride to show you the effects
of political correctness identity
politics cancel culture the film takes
you through the impact on college
campuses big tech Hollywood no safe
spaces argues that free speeches is
important in society and more than that
it shows you how it's being threatened
and more importantly than that it shows
you what we can do to fight back against
those threats it's not your typical
documentary it has animation recreations
plenty of Adam Carolla signature humor
as well no safe spaces takes you behind
the scenes on Ben Shapiro's riot filled
trip to UC Berkeley the god-king of the
daily wire has a cameo I'm even in the
movie for a split second so you could
watch it just for that reason alone if
you can spot me in the movie then I'll
send Prager to your house to wash your
car which is I which I feel like is a is
a is something that needs more
explanation but I'm not gonna give you
more explanation no safe space is rated
pg-13 in theaters Friday December 6 go
to no safe spaces dot-com slash Walsh
for ticket information and theater
locations okay we'll go to emails now
Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com this is from Brandon
says hi Matt maybe you already covered
it but what did you think of Tim Ryan's
comments about Lamar Jackson yeah
Brandon I didn't I didn't actually cover
it for anyone who didn't hear about this
a 49ers radio announcer got suspended
from his job after he said a few days
ago that one of the reasons the Niners
struggled against Lamar Jackson last
week is that they couldn't see the ball
on play-action because the ball blended
in with his jersey which was black and
also his dark skin color that's what Tim
Tim Ryan said and by the way I was
reading an article in the San Francisco
Chronicle about this and it identified
Ryan as the Niners color analyst and you
cannot convince me that that was not
supposed to be some kind of pun but what
do I think about what he said well it's
stupid obviously I mean you might as
well say that white players have an
advantage because the the baseball
blends in with their pasty white skin it
just it doesn't make any sense so it's a
dumb comment and it's one that as a
broadcaster in the year 2019
you have to know
you have to know that it's gonna spark a
significant backlash it's just you gotta
know that come on you you you so it's
it's it's not something that I would at
all defend because it's dumb it's
inaccurate clearly and it's just as a as
a professional broadcaster you you gotta
know better than that
now does this make Tim Ryan a racist
well I don't know anything about Tim
Ryan no nothing about him whatsoever
Richard Sherman the the cornerback now
for the for the San Francisco 49ers he
was interviewed by about this and he
said he wasn't that offended by the
comment he knows Tim Ryan and knows that
he's not a racist so I'll defer to
Richard Sherman on that this particular
comment does does it make him a racist
no of course it does it's stupid you
could say it's racially insensitive if
you want to find the most negative
possible interpretation of it you could
say that he was trying to diminish
Lamar's accomplishments by crediting his
skin color rather than his skill that
would be the most unflattering possible
way to translate what he said and even
that and I'm not really sure that that's
what he actually set out to do but even
that wouldn't be racist okay being a
racist means that you think a particular
race is inferior to you to your race so
the fact that Tim Ryan said that the
ball blends in with Lamar Jackson skin
does that mean that he's saying that
Lamar is inferior to him no and that
that's that's a hell of a stretch
I think we have to be able to sometimes
to say look somebody said something dumb
about race
without automatically concluding that it
makes them a racist it is possible to
say stupid stuff about race and racial
issues without being a racist
automatically
so I think Tim Ryan yeah he was
suspended and and of course that that in
you know the 49 are suspended of course
they're going to in and from their
perspective it's like you're you're you
work for us this is not we don't hire
you to bring in this kind of attention
to us so you're gonna be but I I don't
think it should be fired for it I don't
think his life should be destroyed I
think unfortunately maybe it will be
because that's the culture we live in
but you suspend him for a game you made
your point and he gets back to it and
and we move on it's not really not a big
deal at the end of the day okay
from
Joshua says dear Matt I'm a 20 year old
named Joshua enjoys listening to your
wise and witty musings from the comfort
of convict land elsewhere known as
Australia however I must protest your
cultural ignorance Australia is a lazy
country founded by criminals that we
speak the English language at all is an
accomplishment it is common practice
here to shorten words such as Australian
tracksuit breakfast and McDonald's to
Aussie trackies brekkie and MCEs
respectively McDonald's is MCEs
now in this country you'll hear people
say Mickey D's which I don't like that
but it makes its its sounds a lot makes
more sense than maccas I ask forgiveness
and compassion for the oddities of
Australian slang and apologize deeply
for any that has seeped into the United
States yeah Joshua I got several emails
from folks in Austria in a in Australia
defending brekkie on the basis that it's
some kind of cultural thing I must say
that I do not accept your apology it is
no excuse you guys don't have the right
to just hang out over there on the
bottom of the world abbreviating
whatever words you want okay like you
think nobody notices you think oh we're
in Australia
no one's know it's this is a society
dammit there are rules
words have you can't just attach an IE
or a wide any words you want who do you
people think you are what where do you
get off doing this so your ancestors
were convicts anyway you think that
gives you a pass to continue acting like
barbarians
we all had ancestors who at one point
peed in pots in their bedrooms and then
dumped the contents of the pot into the
street they would just open the window
and dump the pot out into the street
doesn't matter if there's any walking
below doesn't matter watch out here it
comes well you know what I do I use a
toilet
okay because just because my ancestors
did that doesn't mean that I'm gonna do
it because I'm civilized damn it so you
must stop this Australia you can stop it
right now I demand it is not okay
it doesn't even doesn't make sense
because Breck okay brekkie that's two
syllables brekkie Breck II breakfast
it's also two syllables you're not even
saving any time what's the point that's
another thing as you know you add this
to the list of rules but as dictator I
will of course ban attaching ie or Y to
the end of words where it doesn't belong
but in general abbreviating a word where
the abbreviation is just as long as the
original word or even in some cases
longer that's not gonna be allowed
alright we'll go to Ross says dear
future theocratic dictator under your
regime what will be the standard
breakfast sandwich to me it should be
two eggs broken yolk but not scrambled
in a cast-iron pan with bacon or sausage
patty and a slice of sharp cheddar
cheese bread should be honey wheat
toasted of course with mayonnaise or
butter I'll admit the mayonnaise seems
strange at first but I try to under the
advice for my sister and now it's a
staple of my breakfast sandwich please
let me know so I can plan accordingly
for a swift death death or a hope that
everyone will enjoy the best breakfast
every single morning love the show well
Ross you were on the right path until
you got to the bread and condiment
choice and the whole thing just went off
the rails and hundreds of people died in
the wreckage let me clarify this the
correct breakfast sandwich not breakfast
San not-not-not brekkie sandwich well I
guess as they would say in Australia
brekkie Sammy is that what you guys say
I bet it is what'd you say
yeah could I have a brekkie Sammy no the
correct
breakfast sandwich would be two eggs
sunny-side up sausage I'm sorry but
bacon is an inferior choice for a
breakfast sandwich and then as you say
sharp cheddar cheese American cheese is
a disgrace anathema and then you're
gonna either use regular white bread or
if you want to get fancy you can use rye
honey wheat bread is for children grow
up you should be embarrassed and then
you're gonna use butter
you're gonna butter both sides you're
gonna throw the bread onto the pan for a
quick toast or or into the broiler for a
quick toast okay it's not a full-on
toast you want the bread to still have
some give it to it but really this is
about you just stiffen the bread a
little bit and it's also about making
but make sure the butter is melted and
you put some salt and pepper on that
you're just gonna enjoy it that's it you
don't need to add anything
no no mayonnaise god forbid you put
ketchup on it look if you want to put
some hot sauce on the thing I'm not
gonna stop you
I think it's unnecessary but if you want
to that that will be acceptable nothing
else needs to be added to it and but
thank you for that question these are
the kinds of issues that I like to
address on this show and I think we'll
leave it there on a Friday I hope you
guys have a great weekend
go Ravens of course and Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we will get a whole lot
of that and much more
see you there